so the news has just come through at the
2011 Nobel Prize for Physics the Nobel
Prize has just gone to three astronomers
respawn water and Schmidt who between
them get the whole prize and I think the
way it splits up is Perlmutter gets half
of it and recent [ __ ] get a call to each
actually it turns out one of these three
is a mate of mine Brian Schmidt and I
were graduate students together many
years ago in fact he was you know a year
or so below me in graduate school so
little Brian has now won the world prior
to shot past me to glory and clearly
I've you know not been doing the right
things in my career but I'm very pleased
for him he's one of the nicest guys I
know so I'm delighted they got the prize
is everyone in the building talking
about this today have you bumped into
people in the coffee room and they're
all saying what do you think um I want
to talk about it but it seems like a lot
of people haven't been I came into the
tea room and told all the grad students
and it didn't seem to care very much but
maybe maybe was just too early in the
morning they've won the prize for very
carefully measuring the brightness of a
handful of little dots and learning that
they're not as bright as they expected
them to be and this just has very
fundamental implications for measuring
the the fate of our universe
Brian's very interesting guy he actually
it is in Australia now he has many
talents one of which is for example he
runs his own vineyard she actually makes
his own wine which I'm told is very good
I get to actually taste it but I'm told
it's extremely good and in fact Brian
and I have a bet because I bet a number
of years ago that this result was wrong
and so I have a bet I bet of a crate of
his wine from his vineyard against a
really good bottle of malt whiskey that
his results were going to go away and I
think now he's won the Nobel Prize I'm
gonna have to pay him to be honest so
the science that they've been doing is
that these guys have been studying a
particular type of supernova thing
called a type 1a supernova essentially
it's just a particular kind of supernova
just exploding star stars at the end of
their lives and this particular
designation refers to a particular kind
of supernova which has a rather unusual
property which is that they're all the
same and it's quite unusual in astronomy
to have things which are all the same
you know most types of supernovae for
example some of them are brighter some
of them are fainter the interesting
thing about this type of supernovae is
that
when you see one you've seen them all so
actually they all seem to blow up in
exactly the same way they're kind of
dull because you hasn't said you if
you've seen one you've seen them all but
but actually that's also what makes them
exciting because one of the things we
struggle with in astronomy is things
which are just kind of a standard right
things that we can actually compare to
one another so they're what's known in
astronomy as standard candles they're
all the same brightness if you have
something that is a standard candle it
means you know what its intrinsic
luminosity its intrinsic brightness is
because when we make observations of
objects in the universe sometimes if we
don't know how far away they are we
don't know if we're looking at you know
a bright searchlight very far away or a
little glowworm right next door but if
we know the intrinsic luminosity if we
know that what we're looking at is a
hundred watt bulb
then we can fold that into how far away
that object is based on how bright it
appears to be but what's thought to
happen is it's thought these are binary
stars you've got two stars in orbit
around another one of them is a white
dwarf no white dwarf is the end product
of you know a medium class star like our
Sun at the end of its life puffs off its
outer layers collapses but can't
collapse all the way because of
something called electron degeneracy
pressure holding it up so this white
dwarf stays there for a while and the
other is just a normal star and during
the course of its lifetime this normal
star is losing some of its material onto
the white dwarf now the thing about
white dwarfs is that they have a maximum
mass at which they're stable called the
Chandrasekhar limit and that's 1.4 times
the mass of our Sun and so as long as
it's less than that it'll just sit there
as a white dwarf and this other star
will dribble more and more and more
stuff on it until eventually it will
dribble that little bit too much on that
will tip it over this edge and at that
limit this is an unsustainable system
and it triggers an enormous
thermonuclear reaction and causes this
star to explode and that's why we think
they're all more or less the same
because actually it's always at this
same mass where these things go unstable
so it's not like there are different
masses of white dwarf exploding it's
just when they tip over this magic mass
called the childís a car mass that they
all blow up as supernovae they're all
the same and these things can be as
bright as an entire
Aleksey for a couple of weeks and
because they've come out of this sort of
standard origin process this is why
they're very good candidates to be
standard candles
the supernova physics although it's
interesting is not the thing they got
the price for the thing they got the
price for is using them as the standard
candles using them as a way to sort of
measure the entire universe and because
they're so bright we can see them at
enormous distances away we can see the
right across the universe which means we
really can use them to probe the
properties of the universe as a whole
they found that the ones in the distant
universe were slightly dimmer than
expected given their distance and what
this is telling them what this is
telling us is that something the
universe itself has expanded more than
we think it had it should have this was
surprising because actually cosmologists
before this thought that the universe
was de-accelerating going slower because
if you can imagine universe is expanding
which you know that for Hubble in the
1930s that the the mass would push stuff
and make it go slower but they found as
accelerating which was completely
unexpected the genius of it was that
it's very umbilicals by the way this is
the first Nobel Prize ever that used
optical telescopes and astronomy there's
been once for radio but never for
optical the challenge of actually making
these observations and gathering enough
supernovae to make the measurements that
you need to is quite a difficult one
because supernovae are rare a
particularly type 1a supernovae which
which is what's needed for this project
the genius behind it was that they used
the telescope's in a way that was novel
that they went and they they search for
these these stars blowing up and if you
you know 20 years ago and they started
this kind of thing if you told a
telescope allocation committee I want to
take pictures of galaxies and then
retake pictures of galaxies to find
supernovae and the distant universe they
would have thought you're you were crazy
and they I think they did have a hard
time getting a telescope time to do this
what these projects did was put together
an industrial supernova Factory in a
sense
so they got telescope time they had big
enough camera
that they could serve a large patches of
sky around new moon when the skies dark
and then go back and revisit those same
patches three weeks later and then
simply by blinking the two images
together you look for a little tiny
change a little dot coming up
perhaps associated with galaxy which is
going to be that supernova and because
you're surveying such a large patch of
sky you statistics tell you that you
will find some supernovae you don't know
exactly where they will be but you will
get a sample and those samples then you
take away to other telescopes and you
follow them up because what you want to
do the important thing for supernovae as
a standard candle is to catch them at
their peak brightness when these guys
first started finding the results in the
1990s this was a complete game-changer
you know not what anyone was expecting
everyone was expecting that actually
gravity was going to be slowing down the
expansion of the universe and therefore
probably you know that they should be
measuring the deceleration effect and
they started measuring this acceleration
effect which is kind of overturned that
almost our complete understanding of
cosmology and as it had led us to
worrying about things called
cosmological constant and dark energy
and all the things that now now going
into modern cosmology that seem to be
leading to this accelerating expansion
of the universe but this was really the
observational result that set that whole
ball rolling Brian's going to be a busy
man today I suspect he's gonna I haven't
yet bothered just try and put a call
through to him because I think he's
going to have plenty of people on the
phone to him today when are you going to
contact him about this risky then I
think it's girl wait a few weeks